you've made this new animated short film
and you it's it's really lovely it's and
it's a great message here we are
notes for living on planet Earth let's
talk about it
because how long has it been in the
works for I probably got involved in
around a year ago there's an Irish kids
altar called Oliver Jeffers and we have
a bunch of his books he breaks he's a
youngish guy he's probably my age and
from Belfast and I bumped into him at a
u2 gig and we kind of stayed in touch
and he done the animations for the
backdrop in Madison Square Garden it was
really cool and we had his all his books
and happened to be reading him to the
kids and then they got in touch and said
they were doing this so it seemed to
make sense it's a gorgeous story about
explaining the world to a child
basically kids thing it's it's really
adorable and it's a kid who basically is
wants to know everything about Earth
wants to learn is everything he can
about earth and it's an animated film
that's only what half an hour long it's
30 minutes right right it's it's like
for TV so it's like yes it's a half hour
yeah Meryl Streep kind of pleased that
she's been now raised her who's kind of
mother earth and myself and ruth negga
paired parents and Jacob Tremblay but
it's it's very sweet they're kind of
it's set around Earth Day and the kid
wants to go to the museum and his
parents are essentially saying let's go
out and see the world the timing isn't
idea but but it's a beautiful little
tale of just trying to break things down
into the their simplest form so they can
be consumed by it well it's also it's a
nice message this is our planet this all
we have we got to take care of it which
so far so far yeah yeah I'm sure we'll
find another one very soon
yeah but that'll be three years away
that's one it's this is also you've done
your fair share have you've done some
work in animation you've done voices are
your children aware do you have have you
done stuff
your children can watch it and say oh
wait that's that's dad yeah yeah we
raised it kids show on Netflix called
puff and rock these guys from Ireland
and it's very gentle easy show just set
on like clips somewhere it's very sweet
so for the first kind of when you when
we started watching letting the kids
watch TV was all we would let them watch
because it's so gentle but it did mean
for good two years they thought I now
rage at all of television which is maybe
an idea it's sweet yeah nice that they
thought their father was really the
center of the universe this was my
experience when my kids were young they
would fall in love with the show and
then they would get me they would love
it so much that I would mention the show
in interviews then the people who ran
that show would reach out to me and say
Conan do you want to do a voice on the
show and I'd say sure and I would do it
in it's animation so it wouldn't come
out for a year a total year later when I
did the kids had outgrown that show hey
you know I'm on the goo-goo brothers no
one watches the googly brothers well
we're into now is Teen Titans go and I
said like okay great and then I do that
and be like no no we outgrew that oh
shoot
so I was always behind always behind
yeah what so how do we how do we remedy
that I'm you're gonna need to get on
trend for kids stuff of the future yes I
know I know I think what I have to do
now is forget them and aim for
grandchildren that's what I have to do I
have to have to start working on
something now that will come out in 20
years
tomorrow see ya and you thought it was
an idiot I read that editorial you wrote
[Laughter]
weird thing for me to choose no the iris
usually piss on the iron right well let
me try I
I mentioned this here we are notes for
living on planet earth is now streaming
on Apple TV plus great every
everyone should check that out because
it's like yeah and this was nice of you
to take time away from the excrement the
bitter feelings between yourself and
your okay yes yes yes yes
okay we'll uh okay yeah I know it's
great it's just a little bit at home you
know it's great being at home and I'm so
happy for you that you're gonna be there
there's gonna be a van that comes to
your house
get in the back okay don't ask any
questions okay thank you very much for
doing this you're a good sport
you're a fine lad if that's something
people really say Chris Oh dad
god bless you be well be well